chelsea ist eine deutschlehrerin an der
usb und sie hat uns heute eingeladen
ihre klasse zu besuchen und mit ihren
studenten ein video zu drehen was ist
unser thema heute was ist ein deutsches
lieblingswort
ich bin gespannt was die studenten sagen
los geht's
was ist ein lieblingswort gemütlichkeit
und warum ist gemütlichkeit ein
lieblingswort
es war es meiner lieblings gefühl ist
gemütlich ist ein besonderes wort auf
deutsch und es gibt ähnliche wörter in
den niederlanden in dänemark in den
skandinavischen ländern
diese worte beschreiben ein gefühl und
es ist nicht ganz übersetzbar wenn etwas
gemütlich ist dann ist eine umgebung
besonders freundlich besonders warm und
dazu trägt nicht nur die physische
umgebung bei meine wohnung kann
gemütlich sein
aber meistens ist es auch die soziale
atmosphäre ich fühle mich gemütlich in
meiner familie oder bei meinem freund
was ist dein lieblingswort hundemüde
warum ist das dein lieblingswort war
diese welt sehr beschreiben für mich
hilfe es beschreibt wortwörtlich wie du
dich fühlst warum hund warum es ein hund
da drin
ich würde sagen schmetterling bei wenn
er mal ein amerikaner mir fragt was ist
ein lieblingswort auf deutsch
das sage ich auch weil sie denken immer
so lustig ist weil die schmetterlinge
ein sehr hartes wort ist aber eigentlich
ist deutsch eine ziemlich schöne sprache
und man sieht dass nicht wirklich auf
die der internet aber ja das ist nicht
so es hängt davon ab wie man das wort
betont es gibt so viele witze im
internet wo deutsche einfach
schmetterling sagen und dann klingt das
sehr hart aber man kann auch einfach
schmetterlings sagen und dann ist es ein
wunderschönes wort was ist dein
lieblingswort mein lieblingswort ist
genau genau
ja weil es sehr einfach ist man kann das
einfach benutzen genau genau dann kann
man kann hier einfach alles mit genau
beantworten ja genau
becker was ist da im lieblingswort mein
lieblingswort ist verblüfft ja es ist
lustig in beiden sprachen in englisch
ist vorbei das sind durch das ist ein
bisschen lustig ja du hast recht es
klingt in beiden sprachen sehr lustig
daniel was ist ein lieblingswort mein
lieblingswort ist wunderbar
warum wunderbar weil weil die welt
wunderbar ist das gefällt mir mich auch
hält sie jetzt möchte ich von dir wissen
was ist dein lieblingswort eichhörnchen
eigentlich weil es einfach schön klingt
und unmöglich auszusprechen ist aber du
sagst es perfekt danke ich habe
jahrelang daran gearbeitet ein recht ich
mag auch alle komposite zbv tier weil
sie ganz logisch sind und daran liegt
die schönheit der deutschen sprache
meiner meinung nach also du magst diese
besonders langen nomen ja auch wenn sie
ein bisschen schwierig auszusprechen
sind aber eichhörnchen ist so ein wort
was für englische muttersprachler
schwierig auszusprechen ist und das
englische wort ist für deutsche
unmöglich auszusprechen ich kann das
auch nicht sagen lacht hinter der kamera
hast du ein lieblingswort ja mein
lieblingswort ist katze weil katte oder
camp oder koska das ist immer mein
lieblingswort in allen sprachen
warum ich liebe katzen sie sind
wunderbar ich liebe die eidechsen auch
erwachsen sind immer zuerst in meinem
herzen
er will dann hast du ein deutsches
lieblingswort ich denke mein
lieblingswort ist lebenskünstler
das ist ein super tolles wort ja warum
ist das dein lieblingswort ich denke
weil es mich so ein bisschen motiviert
nicht immer so pessimistisch zu sein
ich denke immer leute die aus allen
situationen irgendwas machen können sind
sie meine motivation war für mich ist es
immer alles wird schiefgehen und war es
ist das ende der welt so ich lasse mich
gern inspirieren von leuten die einfach
aus jeder situation das beste machen was
heißt dass lebenskünstler so
lebenskünstler sind leute die auch wenn
es mal probleme gibt die einfach immer
eine lösung finden und sich immer
arrangieren und aus allem irgendwie das
beste machen und optimistisch sind und
ja immer denken ich finde eine lösung es
wird irgendwie klappen
also sie machen aus dem leeren eine
kunst genau das würde ich auch gern und
jetzt seid ihr dran wir wollen von euch
wissen was ist euer lieblings wort und
warum schreibt uns einen kommentar wir
freuen uns da
und ihr könnt wie immer mehr lernen mit
easy german wenn ihr ein mitglied werdet
bei easy german dann bekommt ihr jede
woche interaktive übungen vokabel listen
und vieles mehr
ihr könnt das mal ausprobieren hierbei
patchen das ganze kostet nur 1 dollar
pro woche und ihr könnt jederzeit
kündigen
also ihr sollte das unbedingt
ausprobieren hier könnt ihr sie german
abonnieren
tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]